PROFESSOR: So now we're ready
to put together the facts
that the gcd is a
linear combination
to prove two cool
results-- one fun,
and the other
important and serious.
Let's begin with the
Die Hard example.
So we looked at the
Die Hard state machine,
and we figured out
the behavior of it
with jugs of size
3 and 5 gallons,
and also with jugs of
size 3 and 6 gallons.
Let's look at the
general case now.
Suppose that I have
jugs of a gallons
and b gallons, where a and
b are positive integers.
Now, when we looked
at the state machine,
we figured out that
under the Die Hard rules,
the number of gallons in
each bucket at any stage
is a linear combination
of the bucket sizes.
So at any point after any
sequence of moves of Die Hard
moves, in each bucket there will
be a linear combination of a
and b.
Now, the point is that linear
combinations of a and b
are the same as
multiples of the gcd.
The reason is that the gcd is a
divisor of a and b, of course.
It's a common divisor,
and therefore it
divides any linear
combination of a and b.
So any linear combination of a
and b is a multiple of the gcd,
and the gcd is itself
a linear combination.
So linear combinations
of a and b
are the same as
multiples of gcd.
So that gives us a
pretty good understanding
of what the amounts that we can
get in the various buckets are.
We can only get multiples
of gcd's, but in fact, you
can get any multiple of the
gcd of a and b into a bucket,
providing it will
fit in the bucket.
That's the same
as saying that you
can get any linear combination
amount of a and b into a bucket
if there is room for
it in the bucket.
So let's see how to do that.
So suppose I have a linear
combination of a and b,
sa plus tb, that
will fit in bucket
b, meaning it's greater
than or equal to 0,
and it's less than b.
So it's a number of gallons
that could fit into bucket b.
How do I get that
amount into bucket b?
And here's how.
We can assume that
s is positive.
We've already seen that we can
arrange that to be the case.
And so what we're going to do is
repeat the following procedure
s times.
I'm going to fill up bucket
a and pour it into bucket b.
Whenever b gets
filled up, I'll just
dump it so that it's empty, and
I can keep filling up bucket a
and pouring it into bucket b.
And I repeat that s times.
Now, when I do that,
the total number
of times that I've filled
bucket a is s times.
So the total amount
of water that I
have taken from the faucet,
or from the fountain,
is s times a.
And I've poured it
into b and then dumped
it, leaving only some amount
that's in b that's less than b.
So the amount that's left
after pouring in sa gallons
and dumping out
what won't fit, I'm
left with some amount that's
non-negative and less than b
in bucket b.
OK.
Now, the point is that the
number of emptyings of bucket b
must be exactly t, which is why
the amount of water that's left
in bucket b is sa minus tb.
And the reason why
it has to be minus t
is that if I've got sa there,
if I had more than t emptyings,
I would have had
bucket b go negative.
There just isn't
enough room for it.
And if I had fewer
than t emptyings,
then the bucket would have an
amount larger than b in it.
So the only possible number
of emptyings of b is minus t.
Remember, t is negative, so
minus t is a positive number.
And that means that I've
put in sa and taken out tb,
and I'm left with exactly the
linear combination sa minus tb.
So in fact, there's
no need to count,
because you don't need
to know what s and t are.
Because knowing that you can
get any desired amount that's
a multiple of the
gcd into bucket b,
you just keep doing
this process until you
get the amount that you want.
So you fill bucket a.
You pour it into b.
When b fills, you empty it.
You just keep track of how many
gallons there are in bucket b,
and you keep going until you
get the amount that you want.
And then you're done.